hello readers
once upon a time in the previous century
there lived a cartoonist and engineer
named rube goldberg who became well
known for his drawings of wacky
over-complicated machines this is one
such machine the self-operating napkin
you see how it works is you lift the
spoon which jerks the string which
causes the cracker to leap up into the
air which distracts the parrot and on
and on and on and on and on until
finally you cut the string which
releases this pendulum attached to the
clock which
has a napkin on the end of it which
swings back and forth repeatedly bonking
you in the face i bring this up not
because i think anyone should ever build
this machine it would in fact be
extremely dangerous
you can see that it contains knives and
fire and a small rocket but i want to
show you this in order to
demonstrate a really explicit example of
a cause and effect relationship each
object has an effect
on the next object
and and language can be used in very
much the same way
that's what we're talking about today
cause and effect a cause is why
something happens
and an effect is the result so for this
machine the cigar lighter lights a fuse
which sets off the rocket which has a
sickle a kind of knife connected to it
which cuts this string so why did the
rocket take off well
the cigar lighter lit the fuse
that's the thing that caused it
what was the effect of the fuse being
lit the rocket takes off but the rocket
taking off is its own cause
that causes an additional effect which
is cutting the string
we can see this very clearly in writing
when an author gives us clue words about
how information is connected about how
or why things happen in a text so with
that in mind here are some words that
signal cause
because
since due to as a result of
whereas here are some words that signal
effect so
this is why
consequently therefore am led to
certainly these aren't the only words or
phrases that signal cause or affect but
they are useful ones to look for
it's important to remember that cause
and effect doesn't always go left to
right it's not always going to be as
straightforward as because i was tired
cause i took a nap effect like it's not
always gonna
go cause to effect you could just as
easily write that sentence in the
opposite order
right i took a nap effect because i was
tired which is the cause
the nap doesn't cause me to be tired i
was tired which is why i napped you
can't just figure this out by looking at
the the sentence and the order the words
come in you have to think critically
about what you're reading and consider
how the actions connect to each other
how does it happen
why does it happen so let's take this
opportunity to apply this to a text
example so i'm going to read this
passage and then i'll try to answer a
couple of questions about it so i'll
make a couple of little notes and
annotations as we as we scribble our way
through fourteen-year-old michaela de
prince sat on the shiny hallway floor
and tightened the ribbons on her ballet
shoes okay so she's a
ballerina
it was 2010 and she was about to dance
for the chance of a lifetime that sounds
important an opportunity to earn a
scholarship to a famous ballet school
all right so that's that's our chance of
a lifetime she was in the finals of the
world's largest ballet competition for
young dancers youth america grand prix
but michaela was worried she was nursing
an injury
michaela understood that dancing on her
injury could snap a tendon
that could put an end to all of her
hopes and dreams a tendon is similar to
a muscle it helps you move parts of your
body michaela was devoted to ballet she
had spent thousands of hours practicing
she had worked incredibly hard and had
overcome many challenges to make it to
this point so when they called her on
stage
she danced
and here we have
so which is one of our one of the the
words that we're looking for that
signals that there's a cause effect
relationship so question number one why
was michaela worried michaela was
worried we can even do this by filling
out a little form
right have our little underline
the cause because here the effect
goes here so what what is the cause of
that worry so in the effect box i'm
gonna say
worry that's the effect but why is
michaela worried well she was nursing an
injury and not just that she was injured
but if she pushed that injury too far
and snapped a tendon it could put an end
to all of her hopes and dreams that is
extremely serious so that injury
represents a lot more than just
temporary pain it represents a possible
end to her hopes and dreams so what that
injury could be its potential outcomes
its potential effects
are what are causing her to worry
another question is why did she dance
despite her injury so i'm going to say
that the effect is that michaela danced
and we can see a couple of explanations
in the text right first of all they
called her on stage so she was asked to
do it and she danced but why did she
dance even though she was injured part
of it is that she'd already overcome
many challenges she spent thousands of
hours practicing she'd work incredibly
hard and also here was this opportunity
of a lifetime
so even though she was hurt she still
danced and she did it because she was so
devoted to ballet
that she wanted to get that scholarship
to the ballet school
so i'm going to say that the cause
the reason that michaela danced even
though she was injured is because the
opportunity was so great so the
opportunity the chance to earn a
scholarship to the ballet school
that's the cause and the effect of that
is that michaela chose to dance even
though she was injured and finally what
happened when they called her on stage
what did michaela do well it's right
there at the very end of the paragraph
when they called her on stage she danced
what makes this passage challenging is
there's not a lot of
clue words
that that tell you explicitly hey this
is a cause and effect relationship we've
only really got this so
there aren't other becauses or
therefores or consequences so we really
have to put it together on our own to
figure out how all these different
events
are related to each other and that kind
of brings us back to our old friend rube
goldberg because if we're thinking about
cause and effect we should be thinking
about all of the downstream effects too
because it's possible to say
lifting the spoon
causes
the napkin to wipe your face
even though there are all these other
stages in between but a text won't
necessarily spell it out as plainly as
this very silly cartoon
but i do hope that because you have
watched this video you will therefore
better be able to understand a cause and
effect relationship in writing
you can learn anything
dave it out